el met gala es a la moda lo que los
Oscar son al cine Como todos los años se
vieron los outfits más extravagantes en
la cena benéfica donde un lugar cuesta
5000 dólares destinados a financiar el
instituto del vestido del museo
Metropolitano de arte de Nueva York el
tema de la velada de esta edición fue en
honor al diseñador alemán cara lagerfeld
quien va a inaugurar una gran exposición
Durante los próximos días el actor
Jeremy pop probablemente encontró el
tributo más largo con esta capa de 9
metros otros prefirieron imitar el
legado de lagerfeld
la huella de Carl lagerfeld en la
industria de la moda es inconfundible y
espero hacerle justicia el hecho de que
el diseñador alemán fallecido en 2019
fuera criticado por algunos de sus
comentarios sobre el peso de las mujeres
y el movimiento mitú no pareció molestar
a nadie ni siquiera a Selena Williams
todos jugaron el juego otros como Kim
Kardashian destacaron con Perlas símbolo
de Chanel
y algunos recordar en el amor del
diseñador por los gatos como la rapera
doja Cat o el actor Jared letu
disfrazado de shupete la famosa mascota
de lagerfeld
estoy feliz gracias
mientras Selena Williams y Rihanna
mostraron con orgullo su embarazo
[Música]
el show casi se lo roba un invitado
inesperado esta pequeña cucaracha
captada por los fotógrafos y sin
invitación algunos manifestantes
protestaron fuera del museo contra la
opulencia y el elitismo del evento